-Our next guest
is a talented musician
and actress
whose debut album,
"Snow Angel,"
is available now.
Please welcome to the show
Reneé Rapp, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hi, Reneé. How are you?
-I'm good. How are you doing?
-I'm so happy to have you here.
And I am not alone
this evening.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This -- This must be
a very exciting time.
Your album is
the biggest solo debut
by a female artist this year.
-Yeah.
-Are you happy? Are you?
Are you in fine spirit
about the goal?
-I mean, about this. Yeah.
I think
in general a different answer.
-Good. That's a good point.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. But no, yeah.
-If we just boil it down
to that, there's some happy.
to that, I'm on ten.
-And you've got four shows
in New York City.
We were talking backstage, four
shows in four different venues,
which is, I feel like very kind
gift to the rest of New York.
You're going to make
people commute
as little as possible
to see you.
You're going to come as close
as you can to everywhere, 100%.
-And then I'm just, I guess,
going to make my poor crew,
like, load in and out
twice every single day.
-Terminal 5 tonight.
-Terminal 5, yeah.
-Very exciting.
-Thanks. Thanks.
-This is called the
"Snow Hard Feelings Tour."
-That's right.
-How much work
went into this name?
-Um...
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-I really enjoyed reading it
and like,
realizing what it sounded like
when I said it.
-Yeah, it's a --
It's a chew.
-Yeah.
-I mean, I think we really
did kind of go in on it.
There were like
so many different.
-So you do throw out a lot.
-Oh, we threw around some crazy,
crazy [bleep] but like...
-Who do you trust the most
in that situation?
When you say we, who's your team
when you actually
when it gets down to we're going
to go with "Snow Hard Feelings"?
-Well we have on my, like,
internal team, like, musically
we have we have a group
chat called TikTok hoes.
-Okay.
-And we make a lot of my
creative decisions together.
-Okay.
-So we threw around stuff.
-Well, they say, if you --
if you can't trust the TikTok
hoes, who can you trust?
[ Laughter ]
-I read that in the Bible.
Read that in the Bible.
Yeah.
-You have that extended
version of the Bible
that has a whole --
-[ Laughs ]
-There's a whole section
on text chains.
-It's my version.
-Alright.
-It's from the vault.
It's my version from the vault.
Yeah. We threw around
a bunch of different names,
and then the other day
I was like,
"Should we actually just start
calling this like,
the "Bisexuals Lament?"
Because it's like, me and, like,
two of my really good friends.
And so it's, like, one bisexual
like girl, myself.
If no one was aware.
I never talk about it
or bring it up.
[ Laughter ]
-So this is breaking news.
I can't believe it.
-Huge.
-Yeah.
-I'm excited for you
to come out as bi.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, by the end
of the interview,
let's see where it goes.
I mean, you're making
a very good sales pitch for it.
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
We would --
We would love to have you.
-,Oh my God, thank you.
And I will be allowed
to join the text chain?
-You can join the text chain.
-Okay, good.
You just have to...
We'll talk. We'll talk.
-Okay.
-There's like a lingo.
-Yeah.
Of course. Perfect.
-I don't want
to embarrass myself.
-You won't.
You're a part of the purple,
pink and blue community.
-Thank you very much.
-You're welcome.
-I do -- I have a community
that maybe would take issue
with you, though.
Can I -- Can I speak for
my New England community?
-Oh.
-That one. Yes.
-Okay. Please. So.
All right, so I know
I'm from southern New Hampshire,
so I have a real connection
to Boston, I love Boston,
I can understand why
someone would hate Boston.
Let me make that clear.
As somebody who loves it deeply.
But you have a song
called
"I Hate Boston."
-I do.
and then you put
this billboard up in Boston.
-I did.
[ Laughter ]
-Which seems aggressive.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
Yeah.
-But now the song...
-It is aggressive.
-The song is obviously
not about hating Boston.
-No it's not, it's, I mean,
to be super transparent.
It's not even about Boston.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. It's...
-You could see how Boston might
ask you then why the title.
-Well yeah, of course I just,
I wasn't going to give
my ex's city
any, like, recognition, like.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-I'm not going to,
like, you know,
get on your dad for, like,
cheating on your mom and then,
like, call your city out.
You can do that
on your own time.
-Gotcha.
-You know.
-Where -- Now, where are you
getting all this information
about my family?
[ Laughter ]
-From -- From
the TikTok hoes chat.
-Oh, my God.
-Yeah.
-So you're already
getting my texts,
even though I haven't
joined it yet.
-Bisexuals are going crazy
about you.
-Oh, God. God.
-They love you.
-So, but, this was
to promote your show.
And, obviously,
you have fans in Boston.
-Yeah.
-But what was the response?
Were you hearing how people were
responding to the billboard?
Because obviously your fans
know what it is,
but a lot of people
driving around
Boston are like,
what the heck's going on here?
-Well, like, a lot of, like,
a lot of, like, very, like,
old, well, I'm assuming
like decrepit, like, old,
like -- like white men
who are from Boston.
-Decrepit is our
preferred term.
That's right.
[ Laughter ]
-They love that.
-[ Laughs ]
They -- They were really...
-You really did say it like
you were going
to be more polite.
You were like a lot
of old, apologies.
I mean, not old.
Decrepit.
-Yeah.
-Ancient.
-Yeah. No,
I'm very publicly ageist.
-Yeah.
-A little. A little.
It's just like,
just move --
Whatever. So.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, a lot of people
were upset and I enjoyed it.
-Yeah.
-I enjoyed it.
-I like that
you're admitting, like,
it's nice in this day and age
for you not to, like, backpedal
and say I meant no offense.
-You're just leaning in.
-I meant offense.
-And being like,
I meant offense.
And I'm actually
a little bummed
out more people
weren't offended.
-I'm like,
if the shoe fits,
lace that bitch up
and run.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-You -- You have
a very interactive
and loving relationship
with your fans.
-I do.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And this is a sign
you were holding up.
So I guess you --
Did you see
this sign in the crowd
and then grab it
and then hold it up?
-Yes. Yeah, I did take it.
-This is lovely.
It just speaks to,
I feel like,
how much
your fans like you,
that one of them really
would like you
to hit them
with your tour bus.
-Yes.
Yes. And that picture of me
is one of the --
one of the best.
It's --
It's me in a neck brace
from when I was in
"Mean Girls" on Broadway.
And yeah, I haven't hit anyone
with my tour bus.
However, I will say
the other night
we were trying to go out
in Boston
and like, everything closes
at 2:00 in Boston.
-It's -- It's mind blowing.
-It's really annoying.
-Yeah.
-And I...
-Like you needed another reason.
-Well, I'm like,
"Are you kidding me?"
So we tried to go out.
We couldn't go out anywhere.
We were all in wigs,
having the time of our lives,
of course.
And we ended up just, like, we,
like, played, like,
[Laughs]
like drinking,
like, Olympics style games,
like, on the street
next to the bus.
And we all suddenly
became topless
and really,
like, having fun.
-Yeah.
This is boys too.
-Yeah. Okay.
-Boys too.
And. Yeah.
And Tyler, our friend,
actually did hit the tour bus,
but that was because
he was having fun.
-Okay, so wait.
I think what people think
about getting hit by a tour bus,
the tour bus isn't parked,
but that seems like
in this case,
Tyler might have been at fault.
-Oh, no, we were
running into it too.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, he was --
-He was taking, like,
licks at the bus.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
I think if you,
like, you know,
if Tyler ended up in the ER
and they're like,
"What happened?" If you said,
like, "A tour bus hit him."
-Right.
-People might be like,
"Well, now hold on."
-But not in the mullet.
Not in the mullet
he was wearing that way.
-He was wearing a mullet.
-Well, then I guess it's --
it's a little bit a lot.
-Yeah, it was a lot.
-You're doing
a song for us tonight.
Can you tell us any backstory
about this one?
-Oh, yeah.
Well, the song is called
"Tummy Hurts" and...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thanks, yeah. Yeah, the song
is called "Tummy Hurts."
And I think it's -- it's --
it's kind of like
the I hate Boston sign
in the sense of like
there's -- there's enough
revenge in the song to --
to curse a bloodline.
Okay.
Well, how much revenge
do you ideally
want in each of your songs?
-I think it's case by case.
[ Laughter ]
I think it's case by case.
It's kind of like the lace
the shoe up thing.
It's like if you think
this suits you, put it on.
-Oh. Alright.
So you don't --
You don't specifically reach out
to maybe the party
and say, this is --
this is the song about you.
You just hope that they sort of
find themselves in the lyrics.
-Oh, I don't talk
about the parties.
-Yeah, okay. Gotcha.
-That's why he's not
getting like, the city.
-Right?
-Like, what am I going to give
your city a thing for.
For what you did.
What did you do?
-Yeah. Exactly.
-Yeah.
So yeah.
But I love "Tummy Hurts."
-What do you --
Do you find that you write
your songs very quickly,
like, when you have your ideas
or is it different?
Is that song by song as well?
-I think that's song by song.
It really depends.
Like, I think, like, a lot of it
kind of comes in more of, like,
a, like,
a poetic sort of way.
I don't really -- I wish
I meant that in a hot way,
but I actually just mean it
in the sense of like,
I'll think of, like, a line.
-Okay.
-Like you could put in, like,
a haiku or some [bleep].
And I'll be like, okay,
this will be the song,
and this is where it comes from.
And sometimes that looks like
rewriting the song
like a billion times,
because sometimes
I do get too specific
and people are like,
you're going to --
-Yeah.
-You're going to get
in trouble legally.
You're going to have problems.
I'm like, "I don't care."
And I do, I do care.
I care --
I care quite a bit.
[ Laughter ]
But yeah, so it looks
different all the time.
But I love writing.
-And do you --
Do you get --
How do you get excited?
When you realize you have
a song that you love...
-Yeah.
-Do you get excited
in the process?
Do you --
Does your sort of
does your pulse start to race
when you're like,
oh, I think we got a hold
of a good one here.
-Oh, I get --
I get so excited.
Sometimes
I'm so excited that I cry
because I'm very, like,
I react, like, to music.
I think a lot of people do,
but like for me
it's always been very physical.
Like, I, like,
have little, like,
twitches and, like, tics
and things like that.
And I used to feel,
like, very weird about it.
And now that I work
with, like, pretty much
the same people
all the time,
and I work with, like, a lot of
people who are my best friends,
they, like, see me, like,
tic and like twitch
and, like, start to cry
and, like, hyperventilate.
And they're like,
"Yeah."
[ Laughter ]
-Well,
I'm so happy you're here.
It's such a delight
to meet you.
And I'm so thrilled you're
sticking around
and do a song for us.
-Thanks.
Thanks for having me.
-Alright, you guys,
that's Reneé Rapp.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Her album "Snow Angels'
is available now.
Stick around,
we'll be right back
with a performance
from Reneé Rapp.